the gyro can experience you know like
cauliflower ear you know that is when
guys do [ __ ] up here's from wrestling
I squeeze it I had that inside my nose
so the inside of my nose was all hard
with a lot of people that have been
hitting the nose and like scar tissue
and just it swells well yeah what it is
is when you have blood under skin the
reason why you get calcium or the
cauliflower ear it's actually what
happens is the blood calcifies the blood
actually literally becomes a rock right
so like when you see cauliflower ear
like I've seen guys get their
cauliflower your broken off and it falls
off yeah there's a video this guy he
loses his cauliflower ear see we can
find it Jamie just google kali phos on
the map it's white it's white like a
white stone like now see how it really
is cows sure yeah so that was inside my
nose so they had to open up my nose like
you know with [ __ ] forceps and shad
carve all this stuff out and then they
had a shove these molds like these like
to format yeah what's the foam like like
a hard like a you know soft you know
dense foam so look at that ear on the
ground that is yep but that's that's
just the calcified part that's just the
calcified but it's all the skin attached
to it I was relieved
probably but guys like it because it
makes them feel like a well you can spot
a fighter I'll see him in airports I
mean they're always also in sweatpants
and sliders but yeah that doesn't go
away she fought Jessica I and Jessica I
[ __ ] her here up and to the point
where her cauliflower ear broke off and
you could see inside of her head like
her ear was hanging down you could look
look into her head it's hard to see from
that picture that's not I mean I'm cool
with that
I think about how sweaty my ears get in
these headphones so I can't imagine
being punched in the ear repeatedly well
I always wore a headgear always from
grappling that's why I don't have any
cauliflower ear well so you're not like
a little tiny peices but you know that
little spot little tight spot yeah I
always ask if I can squeeze it and they
always say yes and it's never as
satisfying as I hope it'll walk yeah
yeah I want to squish it Cheers
Randy Couture told me used to shove it
in people's faces like when he was
wrestling he said guys
into people's eye sockets like that
whole thing is a giant rock
well props to him for having the
precision in battle to be able to do
that along all the grappling he's a
savage he just had a [ __ ] heart
attack yeah it's crazy
five years old he was working out and he
was like um I kind of a doctor just went
straight to the doctor and they're like
dude you just had a heart attack I'm
still [ __ ] tough like ya notice so I
eat my own heart
[Applause]